let's talk about the government's top
infectious disease expert he's facing
blowback for appearing to contradict
President Trump over the weekend dr.
Anthony Fauci suggested lives could have
been saved if the President had acted
sooner on warnings about the pandemic
Paula Reid is at the White House for us
and she's been following this Paula good
morning could doctor foul Chi lose his
job over this good morning well Tony the
doctor is under fire from the president
and his allies online after comments he
made over the weekend suggesting that
the Trump administration was slow to
heed warnings about the corona virus
this morning the White House has
declined to comment on our questions
about whether the president has lost
confidence in his top doctor now this
all started over the weekend when the
New York Times reported that the
president was warned about a pandemic at
the end of January and top officials
wanted to implement social distancing in
February now he seemed to corroborate
these reports over the weekend when he
confirmed that he believed that lives
could have been saved if social
distancing had been implemented in
February I mean obviously if we had
right from the very beginning shut
everything down it may have been a
little bit different but there was a lot
of pushback about shutting things down
back then on Twitter last night the
president pushed back against the New
York Times report describing it as quote
fake news and he retweeted a comment
that included the hashtag fire ouchie
that same tweet included a reference to
a February 29th press conference where
the doctor claimed the u.s. overall was
at low risk even though he also said in
that same press conference that the
situation was changing now looking ahead
to reopening the country dr. pouchy said
this won't be a one-size-fits-all it's
not like just flipping a switch he hopes
that at the end of the month the White
House can assess different parts of the
country and look to see if there are
areas where they can start to work with
local leaders to reopen the economy and
as for those much anticipated stimulus
checks over the weekend the IRS said it
has begun sending those to eligible
Americans who already have direct
deposit set up with the government Gail
a lot of news here thank you very much
Paula